[Musique]
élu dès le premier tour avec plus de 57
% des voix nicolas bourdoune en oublie
presque que les mesures de précaution
contre le coronavirus l'héritier naturel
de la maire sortante claudine boisorieux
ne s'attendait pas à une victoire aussi
large
c'est une surprise on a travaillé
beaucoup pour essayer de l'obtenir nous
sommes arrivés c'est le travail de tout
un groupe
je les remercie c'est aussi le travail
de aussi de me la mobilisation de toute
une population
dans un contexte difficile avec
l'épidémie telle qu'on la connaît une
mobilisation pourtant assez faible hier
avec plus de 52 % d'abstention contre
38% seulement aux dernières élections
municipales
ce que déplore l'autre candidat divers
gauche qui termine deuxième avec 25% des
voix
malheureusement avec le conte vos
navires us il ya eu beaucoup
d'abstention beaucoup de personnes qui
sont pas venus voter
est ce que c'est un préjudice pour nous
je pense que oui mais notre travail
n'est pas terminé ici à clamecy on a
encore plein de choses à effectuer
puisque de toute façon on a des voix au
conseil municipal et au conseil
communautaire
un travail qui commence également pour
le rassemblement national après sa
première participation municipale à
clamecy un score de 17% qui ne satisfait
pas son candidat dans d'autres
conditions les score aurait été
différent mais encore une fois il ya des
règles il ya des règles démocratiques
qui sont fixés c'est ainsi l'élection
ait lieu
les clamecy quoi on fait un choix de pas
se déplacer et aujourd'hui pendant six
ans ils auront nicolas bourdoune comme
maire effectivement ils auront à assumer
ce choix puisqu'il est démocratiquement
élu malgré les conditions que l'on
connaît
c'est donc un score sans appel dans la
commune et cela faisait des années que
clamecy n'avait pas connu ça aux
dernières municipales
la maire sortante avait battu son
adversaire d'une petite voix seulement